hey what's going on is Bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday February 5th 2018 what's going on
how how you doing I'm actually doing
pretty good after a Super Bowl loss
congratulations to the Philadelphia
Eagles winning their first Super Bowl
championship bubble the first one first
once the best one if my team hadn't lost
I would have gone online or something
like that just to watch grown men crying
in Philadelphia
over sports which is one of my favorite
things ever
I remember the Patriots won their first
one I was actually at the game
I haven't gone previously two when we
lost the [ __ ] Brett he took off his
helmet and ran down the field I bet his
agent cried on that play we're gonna
make so much money he's so adorable
have you seen a picture of his dick
lately no I just remember one when we
kicked that field goal and we won and
I've got to say we by the way people go
oh we know the field yeah well I get
[ __ ] when my team loses alright whatever
your team wins people go um you weren't
playing but if your team loses then they
guys so suck a dick all right we lost
yesterday anyways I remember when we
kicked a field goal to win the [ __ ]
thing and everybody behind but he
tackled each other and I got up there
was this guy just standing there was
just and hit like tears in his eyes like
he was gonna [ __ ] start crying and my
eyes met his and he was looking at me
it's so weird to this day it's still
weirdest moment that I've had with
another male I could see if we were at a
[ __ ] funeral Jesus Christ
you know man the [ __ ] up and I also
remember
if I was in Philadelphia I would want to
hear from that guy one of my favorite
things this year in the football season
was when dad Kellen carson wentz went
down and that Eagles fan called in the
radio station and started breaking down
crying to the point he freaked out the
radio host he called up he was like sort
of complaining that all the sides just
like going like buddy buddy you're
crying for Alice it's great
it was just [ __ ] great so I would
love to hear that guy's follow-up call
he's probably crying even more so I
really wish when I finally saw the
Eagles win the Super Bowl that they
weren't playing my team so I could have
enjoyed it more because that is
something as a sports fan that I really
enjoy because it's only a two fan bases
that I just worship wish eternal misery
on and that's the Yankees because I have
to the same way they do it with Red Sox
fans and the Montreal Canadiens other
than that you know if you you know I
would never wish that you know a fan
base never got to feel a championship so
congratulations to you guys all right
now having said that I've had that Don
Henley song in my head this whole
morning just thinking about the game
because there's always that [ __ ]
devastating shock when your team loses
and the song I woke up hearing today for
whatever reason was Don Henley's last
worthless evening and I was walking
around the kitchen I was just singing
that was the worst [ __ ] defense that
I've ever seen dude that was the you
know it was an exciting game but if you
really look at it that was arguably the
ugliest [ __ ] Super Bowl I've ever
seen it was like both teams were in a
[ __ ] prevent defense the entire game
that was a [ __ ] Super Bowl people
there was two punts the entire game and
no sacks unless you called call count
the brady fumble which I don't know how
that
if you slap the ball out and then you
tackle the quarterback if that's
considered a sack
I heard them kind of alluding saying
this was the first sack of the game I
was at a Super Bowl party which I
usually don't do but I got a kid now
and I went actually had a good time as a
bunch of kids running around throwing
balls and all that stuff and I was being
the lunatic sitting in the other room by
myself trying to watch the game or
whatever but uh anyways you know what's
great about having a kid you don't have
to watch the halftime show I'll put her
in the stroller go for a walk so I don't
even know who played the halftime I just
kept walking by the front door I kept
hearing music and when the music ended I
came back in and then somebody goes hey
great timing great timing is I thank you
like watched a few of these watched a
good 40 of them anyways I've never seen
like the defense was so [ __ ] bad in
that game it was literally like how did
either one of these teams even make it
here I don't know if it was the weird
matchup or what I mean I don't know
anything about the [ __ ] Eagles
considering I thought that [ __ ]
squirrels guy who was still playing but
I did call it with the running game I
just didn't know is that [ __ ] dude
that you got from the Dolphins whatever
right but I knew that that was going to
be a problem yeah I don't know what the
[ __ ] happened to the Eagles but I will
tell you the New England Patriots the
game this season where I went like oh
boy oh Jesus
we ain't winning it this year was when
we played the Pittsburgh Steelers and we
went down we went down and we scored the
[ __ ] game was over there wasn't
enough time left
even with Big Ben and then we gave up a
90-yard screen pass and the only reason
why we won that game was because of that
stupid [ __ ] is it a catch isn't a
catch now when he catches the ball here
and he turns and starts running with the
ball we don't know if he has possession
as he possesses the ball and reaches
over the [ __ ] goal line right there
my number one thing I want them to fix
in football is that [ __ ] rule
I don't remember that really being a
huge is it a catch isn't an a catch
controversy before they [ __ ] with that
rule so every once in a while you know
you try to make the game less
controversial and you do dumb [ __ ] like
that or even the Tuck rule man was
[ __ ] stupid that was a fumble it's the
stupidest well he tucked it in I don't
know but I don't know the rulebook the
way they do it it's [ __ ] dumb and all
you rate of friends who are jumping up
and down because the Patriots fans said
that that was a fumble go watch the
[ __ ] roughing the passer call that
you guys got back with old Kenny stable
and Ray Hamilton jumping in the [ __ ]
air that gave you a goddamn Super Bowl
okay so why don't you take off your
[ __ ] Rocky Horror Picture Show scary
Raider costume and shove it up your ass
alright I'm sorry still a little upset
that my team lost attacking [ __ ]
Raiders fans who are about to become the
most profitable [ __ ] franchise in the
modern NFL era era the second they go to
Las Vegas they're gonna do so well in
Las Vegas this is my prediction that I'm
gonna say the Rams will eventually move
to Reno or Laughlin Nevada or some [ __ ]
right so anyways getting to the game
that was the ugliest [ __ ] game
collectively of team defense I've ever
seen in my [ __ ] life I don't remember
seeing a punter the whole game I haven't
looked at the stats you know because my
team lost so you know you go on [ __ ]
radio silence I'm not going on social
media because not one Eagle fan talked
to any [ __ ] [ __ ] and I already looked
at my feed last night so look good all
this [ __ ] it's like where was that
before the game when you're green knees
were [ __ ] shaken I think there was
two punts no sacks other than I guess
that Brady thing that they count that is
a sec okay if you told me before the
[ __ ] game started I'll just say cuz I
don't know what happened I'll say the
Eagles punted once and and the [ __ ]
Patriots punted once you just told me
alright
you're not gonna sack Nick Foles once
and the Eagles are only going to punt
once and you'll have one
turn over I'd be like oh boy oh this is
gonna be everything we're gonna get the
living [ __ ] kicked out of us and I bet
if you told me what the [ __ ] ever to the
Eagles defense I thought they were gonna
kill us I was like Jesus this [ __ ]
team looks like those giant teams so
they got that great front four they got
a [ __ ] running game they're gonna
[ __ ] make Brady move and we're gonna
be frustrated they're punting and all of
that [ __ ] and then they're gonna have
the running game chewing up the [ __ ]
clock there was still a great game and I
know there's a bunch of Patriots fans
whining about that trick play who by the
way Cris Collinsworth just couldn't get
over that play going they kept going
back to it look Scotty I placed those
iconic played so well hit it's like you
mean the one the Patriots just ran five
minutes ago you see that at least five
times a [ __ ] year in the NFL regular
season it wasn't like this unique trick
play and if you watch college football
you see at about 40 times a year it's
just the standard [ __ ] play now I
guess illegal formation is if there's
you needed six guys on the line and the
Eagles had five and there was one guy a
[ __ ] hair back so I don't know if you
want to say that's illegal formation
I'll tell you this with the defense
played yesterday and they if they
actually called that the Eagles would
have scored on the next [ __ ] play all
right it'd be one thing if we were
actually stopping them I would actually
look at that be like well wait a minute
blah blah blah blah blah you know my
buddy said something funny he goes you
know what the Patriots scored on that
and we actually won the game they would
be calling it formation gate for the
next three [ __ ] years which is
hilarious we probably would have lost
that draft pick because of that play but
there's no [ __ ] way on any level I
would ever take that victory away from
the Eagles they they totally were they
won the [ __ ] game all right bit and
this is how bad the defense was even on
the last play of the [ __ ] game they
still had to give the Eagles fan base a
[ __ ] heart attack when they batted
the ball all around I mean it like there
was like three Patriots that had a shot
at the ball as it was like hanging in
the
err just a really weird weird [ __ ]
game but I can't say this I am really
happy for for Eagles fans and the city
of Philadelphia and I know that I will
always be sort of connected to that city
as if I [ __ ] hate them I don't I
never did it was just I had a bad show I
was in Philly and I went after this [ __ ]
that you loved but I really the only
time I ever really hated of Philadelphia
team was when the Celtics and Sixers had
that great rivalry but other than that
you know what I mean we're in the AFC
you're in the NFC we were in the addams
division you were in the Patricks
division I actually used to like the
Flyers back in the 80s because I liked
fights and I remember rooting for them I
think they played Edmonton I figured who
they played but they were gonna lose the
game and out of nowhere Ron Hextall had
an absolute [ __ ] fit and for whatever
I've never seen a goalie do this just
skated out of the crease and started
fighting somebody just completely
spazzed out ran out skate it out as you
said but after a while I couldn't become
a flyer I couldn't stay a Flyers fan
because they reminded me of how I was
living my life was like well this worked
[ __ ] 30 years ago let me let me keep
trying it every year you know they kept
trying to beat their way to the cup
because it wanted sit because it won I'm
a cup at 74 75 and then they continued
to do it well into the 2000s so anyways
what else did I made a couple of notes
here I think that was it I think that
was it
anyways but this one it doesn't hurt the
way those giants one's heart this one is
just this one just kind of sucks but
anyways congratulations that's [ __ ]
great so now the Philadelphia Eagles in
the last ten years the Philadelphia with
the city of Philadelphia has won a World
Series and they won a Super Bowl so now
they need the Flyers its 76ers to win
which I don't know how the [ __ ] that's
going to happen so
anyways there you go there's my Super
Bowl chatter once again congratulations
to the Eagles fans and you know Patriots
fans it's a positive that you can take
from it
alright the team come 100% overachieved
this year all right not having Edelman
the whole year haven't Gronk concussed
and Brandon hooks cooks I should say
hooks Brandon cooks essentially knocking
himself out of the game I've never seen
anybody do something like that when he
peeled back I literally yelled what the
[ __ ] is he doing I've never seen a guy
peel back with the ball and be looking
the wrong way and get himself knocked
out of the game they should have been
like Benny Hill music playing I don't
know what the I think he was so
surprised he was that open he didn't
know what to do with he it's like he had
his own public park to himself anyways
here's your uh as Patriots fans how you
can get past this just be happy you know
every every time the Patriots win the
Superbowl you know when you really think
about it you know have you ever gotten a
ring yourself you don't get a ring all
you have to do is now go out and buy a
championship t-shirt and get a
subscription to Sports Illustrated so
it's nice you know to avoid that expense
anyways so there you go and now the
worst feeling ever almost as bad as your
team losing the [ __ ] Super Bowl is
that football season is officially over
no college no pro no Canadian no nothing
whatever you got March Madness coming up
formula 1 starts next month or whatever
but anyways congratulations to the
Patriots on a great season and once
again congratulations to the thesis your
Super Bowl champion Philadelphia [ __ ]
Eagles man who would have ever thought
now wait a minute let's go around the
league so who's left we all know the
Cleveland Browns
and they certainly didn't take a step
towards winning one this year but she
never enough sure they got a bunch of
draft picks let's go run a league
Patriots obviously have one Giants
obviously if one Jets won Super Bowl
Eagles have one Pittsburghers one Ravens
have one Washington is one Carolina
Panthers went to Tennessee Titans lost
to the Rams and one of the great Super
Bowls of all time all right
they never wanted to houston oilers they
did win an AFL title I believe the first
year Jacksonville Jaguars never won so
there's there's three teams sort of
number one and the brown sets for
Bengals never won that's five Lions
never won that's six dolphins have won
Tampa Bay's one Atlanta never won that's
seven oh [ __ ] there's still a lot of
teams left New Orleans is one right
moving on up and then a soda never one
bears of one Kansas City Chiefs one
Super Bowl four Cowboys of one Houston
Texans if number one that's nine Broncos
of one Arizona Cardinals never won
that's ten San Diego Chad just never won
Jesus Christ this is really saying about
how many dynasties has been in football
the Rams never won [ __ ] Raiders have won
49ers of one Seattle of one I probably
missed a team or two they're so 12 teams
haven't wanted 20 teams have well I
guess you know something if when the
Patriots we say the Steelers have won
six Patriots have won five forty nine is
one five and cowboys of one five that's
twenty one of the 52 Super Bowls right
there spread out against with just four
[ __ ] teams Giants got four so that's
twenty four Packers have four that's 20
so that's one for like six teams of 128
of them well I guess that kind of makes
sense then so I guess it's there's
really no shame at this point you know
having never won a [ __ ] Super Bowl
considering like a lot of those teams I
mentioned were expansion teams like the
Panthers Texans and [ __ ] jaguars all
right there you go another goddamn
season out the window and I have to be
honest with you I am really fearful you
know with Tom Brady gonna be turning 41
here that it might be a long long time
before we ever get back to another one
if we don't get back next year because
I'll never forget you know everybody
talks about Dan Marino who undeserving
Lee gets all this [ __ ] for having never
won a Super Bowl I mean the game had
passed his coach by he never had a
running game he never had a defense he
still did what he did was he supposed to
tackle people too and come up with the
[ __ ] game plan the man would
literally throw for 6,000 yards a season
if the rules of past coverage were the
way they are all right now that guy went
to a Super Bowl in his second year I
believe in 1984 not only did the
Dolphins never get back during his
career they've never been back period
since then so that was 34 [ __ ] years
ago Dan Marino was 23 years old he's now
57 that's how [ __ ] nuts this is so
I'm telling you right now when Brady and
Belichick leave you know I'm gonna be 50
years old if we go through what the
Dolphins go through I will be 84 years
old still waiting for them to get back
so I don't take any of this for granted
cuz there's a lot of Patriot the
Patriots good okay you guys must be
exciting anymore it's like now dude it's
[ __ ] unbelievable I'm trying to enjoy
every second of it because I always
think okay this is the last time we're
getting back thank God we won this is
the last time we're getting back [ __ ] we
lost this is the last time oh we lost
again oh we won
we won again now we [ __ ] lot yeah I
don't know I don't know it's [ __ ] you
know and for all you Patriot haters out
there I mean you're really suppose you
said it best he goes it's like you're
literally watching something you're
probably never gonna [ __ ] see again
that level of dominance but I do
understand you know if you love your
[ __ ] team and all that [ __ ] but
anyways I we are deaf and I don't know
where we are in the run we're definitely
in the final 10% of it and I don't know
if that was the last of it we shall see
we shall definitely see but you know
here's the thing I think if they never
get back again in 34 years so they do
either way I'll be sitting there
watching because I have nothing better
to do okay what is that 20 minutes in
all right let's read a little bit of
[ __ ] advertising shall we shall we
alright and og talk about how every man
looks better in a suit I'll tell ya I
don't think I've ever been so starstruck
is when I see Tom Brady in a suit you
know what I mean hair in just all the
perfect places are endowed Chino is the
largest custom apparel company they make
suits and shirts made to your exact
measurements for a great fit yeah so
after you get measured stop [ __ ]
eating stupid or try to remember exactly
what you ate guys love the wide
selection of high quality fabrics and
the options to personalize all the
details including the lapel jacket
lining Eagles fans you can get Super
Bowl champions right your little lapel
monogram and much more here's how it
works
pick your fabric choose your
customization submit your measurements
place your order and wait for it to
arrive in three weeks or less you can
shop online in Indo Chino comm or visit
any of their showrooms across North
America this week my listeners can get
any premium premium Ndoki no suit for
just three hundred fifty nine dollars in
indochina calm
that's IND o CH Ino Indo Chino calm when
entering borough at checkout
that's over 50% off the regular price
for premium made-to-measure
suits plus shipping is free that's Indo
Chino dot-com promo code verb for any
premium suit for just three hundred
fifty nine dollars plus free shipping
incredible deal for a perfectly tailored
suit alright and is the latest always
the latest advertiser I got you've never
turned that's the word you hate the most
when you're married you'd never turn
down the free money right you'd never
turn down free money right that's how
you read it well if you shop online
without the best coupons you're already
paying too much coupons it's for like
old people old people online we'll be
back after these messages
fortunately there's a free browser
extension called honey that
automatically finds the best coupons on
the web so you always get the best
prices on everything online
please personalize this to make it your
own okay in two clicks oh wait let me
make this my own it to [ __ ] clicks any
browser for free then shop like you
normally do honey
scans and tests millions of coupons in
the background at checkout will
automatically apply the best coupon to
get you the biggest discount over seven
million [ __ ] people use honey II
everyday and together they've saved
millions of dollar when high honey's got
your back
you'll never overpay for anything ever
again mandatory personal endorsement
what's the last purchase you made with
honey how much did you save I don't know
how to use it I'm [ __ ] 49 years old
I'll have to figure out how to use this
there's no reason to add honey to your
browser today I'll tell you right now if
I used honey you know what I would use
it for to buy a New England Patriots AFC
championship t-shirt
making a joke about your own team
there's no reason to add honey to your
browser today it's takes just seconds to
install and will save you tons of money
add honey to your browser for free right
now - now join at honey calm h oh and a
why.com / / that's join honey dot-com /
/ alright Dollar Shave Club everybody
Dollar Shave Club
everyone knows Dollar Shave Club ships
amazing razors for a few bucks what you
might not know is that Dollar Shave Club
also has products for pretty much
everything else you need in the bathroom
body wash shampoo hair gel lip balm
everything if you're sick of the
nonsense at the store now's the time to
try out Dollar Shave Club for a limited
time Dollar Shave Club is basically
giving away their [ __ ] shower shave
starter kit starter set sorry two new
members for only five dollars this
starter set feature features their
executive razor and three trial size
versions of their most popular products
that help you stay fresh so fresh and so
clean in your first box you will receive
their shave body wash and one white
cherry on cherry butt wipes you will
receive their executive razor which
includes their premium weighty handle
and focused set of cartridges after the
first box replacement cartridges are
sent for only a few bucks a month this
offer is exclusively available at
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's dollar
shave club comm / / dollar shave club
high-quality products will have you
covered from face cheeks to butt cheeks
there is no better time to try the club
and lastly but not leastly stamps.com
postage rates have gone up again
let's stamps.com keep your rates down
with postage discounts up to 40%
discounts you can't even get at the post
office stamps.com gives you 3 cents on
every letter you
son paid 2016 prices for 2018 stamps
just use stamps calm to automatically
calculate and print the correct amount
of postage for every letter or package
you send stamp stock rom makes it easy
they'll send you a digital scale to
automatically calculate the exact
postage stamps com will even help you
decide the best class of mail based on
your needs anything you can do it at the
post office you can do right from your
desk with stamps calm I use stamps calm
anytime I've sent it out my posters when
I'm on the road right I'm a [ __ ] if I
can figure out so can you and right now
you too can enjoy the stamps calm
service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage
and a digital scale go to Stan stop
clunk calm chase I can't so I got the
Invisalign in sorry people go to Stan's
comm click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in bird that
stamps comm enter BER and look who just
came in the one thing that can put my
smile on my face after a Super Bowl lost
my wife and my beautiful daughter okay
come on in you know what I don't know
what happened last yesterday in that
Super Bowl I can't explain
they should have been Benny Hill music
playing during that game can you give us
our your breakdown honeybunch what
happened
pushing the microphone away you don't
want to talk about you so devastated
that's because you're spoiled because
this high high the Patriots won the
Super Bowl every year of your life until
this year that's right she's one years
old they've already been there twice oh
and all she knew was winning sorry
sorry that you had to learn this ugly
lesson oh my god if they showed Nick
Foles wife one more friggin time I get
it isn't it unbelievable I guess I have
to say as a redhead the way blunt people
get treated I swear to God if she was a
brunette maybe they would have panned
past her face to some fat Eagles fan
eating a cheesesteak I
you can say anything he just thrown your
hands up is it weird that I have
headphones on and a microphone here you
say mama nothing nothing nothing
she's speechless after that loss right
there you go there's a mama do you say
hi do you say hi buddy you could wave
hey who played the halftime show
yesterday oh it was Justin Timberlake oh
[ __ ] I should have watched that I was
pushing her up and down the driveway
having a grand old time
alright alright let's stop stop trying
to show off here let me let me finish my
podcast here
they haven't showed a quarterback's wife
that much since Kurt Warner's you know
although she was a brunette so there
goes that theory alright the stupid
pom-pom hat on you're in an indoor
stadium alright bill don't be a bitter
douche all right I won't congratulations
to Nick Foles wife I was hoping that the
Patriots were going to kick the [ __ ] out
of the Eagles just so I could have seen
this sports headline you know if Nick
Foles threw like three interceptions
they would have said Nick folded but it
didn't happen
alright Formula One let's get to the
questions here this week oh no way I
gotta tell you about my show in Reno so
I want to thank everybody that came out
in Reno even the douche that tried to
interrupt my show and have a YouTube
moment I [ __ ] love that city man I
had such a great time I went up there
and I worked my buddy Rick D'Elia
who we started out together way back in
Boston in 1992 I think he maybe started
like a month before we trying to figure
out who started before but I always
remembered seeing him and you know
seeing a friend you know Jesus Christ me
where I've known him for 26 years I've
actually known him longer than the age
we were at when we met each other so it
was you know just all the stories were
coming out and when he brought me up he
actually made a reference
- this [ __ ] hell gig that we did
Nick's comedy stop where I started they
I remember that was such a big deal to
work at that comedy club just a
legendary place it was a house that you
know Steve Sweeney and Don Gavin and all
those guys built and we were both you
know no-name comics just past being
opened my kurz had started hosting and
like you know outside rooms like dick
Doherty rooms and all of that and Rita
from Knicks called us up to do a private
gig for Nick's comedy stuff and I
couldn't believe it I was like oh my god
things are finally starting to happen
and you know mean the LIA found out you
know we were working with each other
which should have been a red flag right
there
going like they called you - oh my god
they believed in us right that should
have been a [ __ ] red flag right there
because both of us should have been
opening for somebody who knew what the
[ __ ] they were doing but instead we show
up it was the fisherman's feast in the
North End of Boston which is the Italian
section or at least it was back in the
day I don't know what what what goes on
there now everything the prices they
just driven every every any see any sort
of like culture has been removed which
is why I like going to be the so called
B C and D level cities because there's
still that unique vibe there you'll go
there and see stuff that you don't see
in every other [ __ ] city you know the
same ten [ __ ] corporate chains and
whatever everybody walking around with
their Instagram look on their face you
know so anyways we show up to this gig
it's outside literally in the [ __ ]
streets I tell this story last week I
can't remember and it was like a [ __ ]
band on stage right and all the Italians
are sitting there singing and you really
just see that feel this great sense of
family
tradition and culture and now you got
these two pasty-faced you know at least
Rick was half Italian you know I'm
[ __ ] German Irish just standing there
with my [ __ ] fire engine red hair so
D'Elia goes on nobody has any idea
what's like this [ __ ] guys I got now
I got a little comedy about but my bad
at and people like what the [ __ ] is this
guy talking about and then D'Elia goes
on stage trying to smile through
probably the biggest panic of his life
and I remember wanting to laugh at him
but I couldn't because I knew I had to
go on next so whatever he was feeling I
was about to feel but at least I and for
me it was gonna be worse because be at
least before he went on stage he had
[ __ ] hope like well maybe this will
be good but what I saw Rick go on stage
I had confirmation that this was not
going to be good I just remember him
just [ __ ] interrupting this great
[ __ ] party which is so many of the
early stand-up gigs you know just
interrupting something that everyone was
totally enjoying and they really don't
need you and then they don't know that
you're coming up there and then you go
up there and they're like what the [ __ ]
is this all I remember was when I went
on stage bombing and just looking up and
seeing all these old Italian ladies like
hanging out the window just looking down
at us like like what the [ __ ] is this
[Music]
[Laughter]
and just afterwards I forget we probably
walked out of there there's no subway
stop
hurry walked over to our cars
I don't even member name it was great to
work with him but um I was in the middle
of my set having a great time and I do
this bit where I make fun of the troops
a little bit you know what I mean
and it's not even you know it's not even
[ __ ] remotely it's like a [ __ ]
hilarious bit the first time I did it I
did it at a VFW to make sure that you
know the way I was doing it I did in
front of the troops they were all
[ __ ] dying laughing I mean those guys
they that lost their legs over there and
[ __ ] and they was still laugh and they
loved the [ __ ] bit so I do the bit
there you know and I've moved on from
the bit and at this point I'm making fun
of Isis and all of a sudden this this
guy walks all the way up from the back
the room unfortunately the chairs were
like where he couldn't get all the way
up to the front he said yelling at me
pointing at the stage going huh show
some [ __ ] it's what he started see I'm
trying to have his [ __ ] YouTube
moment you know what I mean and I was
like what show some respect for what
he's like doing one of those [ __ ]
things like yell of other military is
just so [ __ ] off limits now that who
supports you just have to constantly be
blowing the [ __ ] military that you
can't even make fun of somebody in the
Navy who all he does is swab the [ __ ]
decks and it's getting a standing
ovation walking through the [ __ ]
airport I've done that [ __ ] pittance
in front of so many troops they've all
found it funny this [ __ ] you know this
fat [ __ ] oh my god I went off on that
guy Joseph why don't you show some
[ __ ] respect and lose some weight you
fat [ __ ] for your fellow American for
every time you get the middle seat on a
flight and your fat [ __ ] mantid spill
into the other I'm so [ __ ] sick I'm
so [ __ ] sick of everybody being so
goddamn [ __ ] offended yet comedy
shows it's just making the whole moment
about themselves
you [ __ ] mouth-breathing chimp jesus
[ __ ] christ
if you can't [ __ ] see through the
[ __ ] whatever that [ __ ] expression
is see the forest through the [ __ ]
trees with all of this [ __ ] I just can't
[ __ ] help you and considering all
this [ __ ] that I had said up until that
point I didn't show any remote respect
for anything
every [ __ ] subject that's what kills
me I blamed women for sexual harassment
that's how I started my [ __ ] show
where was the risk where were the [ __ ]
was he during that one fat [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my god I was so [ __ ] mad at that
guy
I hated that security escorted amount I
appreciated that they did that thinking
that I wanted to it I wanted to talk to
that guy for the rest of the [ __ ]
show walks all the [ __ ] way up you know
he was waiting for his Oprah round of
applause when I told him to go [ __ ]
himself everybody left I can't believe
it you know that's the classic thing at
like a comedy show that usually ends up
on the [ __ ] Internet you don't I mean
that self-righteous [ __ ] douche bag
you know what I mean where everything
else that I said up to that point was so
[ __ ] ridiculous and absurd and then
that's the one that you're gonna take
[ __ ] seriously like what kind of a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that's all saints' it's guys it's like
do you really think I'm anti my own
country you dumb [ __ ] when you guys come
out to my show when you see the bit okay
it's so [ __ ] pedestrian it's
ridiculous I won even though when I did
the [ __ ] bit at the VFW the troops
came up to me so I can't we say that to
each other but this [ __ ] guy had to
[ __ ] you know take his hair out of
his ponytail tossing it around and come
is to have his big [ __ ] head rolling
moment [ __ ] kill yourself I hope you
[ __ ] have a heart attack if that
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know what it was was if
he didn't like the bit then heckle me
the fact that he came up there he's like
pointing at me yelling at me like he's
like I'm his kid he's my [ __ ] dad
anyways anyways let me let me just
[ __ ] plow that other than that the
gig in Reno was [ __ ] awesome and I'll
be telling you that that was actually
more upsetting to me than watching my
team [ __ ] lose the Superbowl let's
get the questions here this week the
formula one oh by the way Oh Billy's
getting in it's continuing with this
getting in [ __ ] great shape man I've
made the denied my goal is you know
turning 50 in June you know two years of
doing stand-up comedy and trying to get
a positive out of a negative five people
showed up what do I do here do I give in
to the fact that there's five people or
do I make those five people which they
brought another fifty you know what I
mean you get when you [ __ ] I don't
know when you're in this [ __ ]
business the greatest thing about
this business unless you knew somebody
when you got into it most people get
into it they don't know anybody and they
have no idea what to do and they're
standing out in the street broad
daylight in the Italian section of
Boston eating your red dick I mean if
you if you don't figure out a positive
mindset you're really not gonna you're
not gonna [ __ ] you're not going to
survive so I'm turning fifty which I
used to think was going to be
devastating I'm actually really excited
to try to get myself in the best shape
I've been in and by about twenty years
so I'm trying to get down to my
basically the weight I was at when in
the shape I was in when I started now
I'm obviously gonna fall short because
no matter what I do I'm still [ __ ]
about thirty years older but that's not
what it's about it's about going for it
and I'll still you know so anyways I
have a weight that I want to get into my
[ __ ] shoulder the rotator cuff feels
great and I finally have been able to
get a regimen between all the
information that I've gotten over the
last year and I've put together a
program that is really [ __ ] working
for me and I have to tell you you know
what I did the other day other than
taking my beautiful daughter to the park
on the swing which I think I'm gonna do
again today it's my favorite thing ever
is she was on the swing and I was able
you know it's once I got the swing going
because I'm I could finally lift my
right arm over my head I've been able to
take my shirt off um with both I've had
to take it out my left hand I've been
able to take my shirt off with with both
hands in like over a year and a half
which it's really [ __ ] up my closing
bit everybody you know because I really
try to get sexy in the end you know I
was actually able to reach up and hold
on to like the bar above the swing and I
made sure I didn't put any weight on the
arm all the way it was obviously my feet
were still on the ground and I just gave
it a little bit of a [ __ ] stretch and
it was just this tight
but not pain because what happens I
found anybody else going through this
[ __ ] is is when you have an injury like
that you get into this protective like
the way you hold yourself and it's
[ __ ] crazy man like having not put my
hand above my head for over a year
like I can't physically do it anymore
because those tendons don't get
stretched then all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
just I don't know grows over it or
whatever they just it's weird it feels
it like doesn't feel like pain it's like
there's a doorstop and I just are a
governor I just can't go any further so
after doing all these other exercises I
end with that and it feels tremendous it
was funny I was doing that while
watching the Super Bowl and one of these
others Patriots fans was laughing I mean
like dude you're really getting into
this game and I was like nah now sorry
man I'm just [ __ ] working out my
shoulder so anyways I hope that helps
anybody out there that has it that that
issue so I'll actually be able to work
out but the great thing is I've
discovered dance working out with bands
[Music]
you know in a door jam and all that
which is really gonna help me on the
road and I think I'm done with the
weight lifting for a long time that's
kind of what got me into this years of
weightlifting and not doing enough back
exercises and the front part of my body
was way stronger than the back and it
pulled my shoulders forward and one of
them came up and then I you know was
bench pressing and just the bones I
don't know that the rotator cuff tendon
just rubbed on it and got inflamed and
then I was just [ __ ] and it's really
something that if I if I if it ever
happens again I'll be able to get out of
it and like you know six to eight weeks
but I just didn't know what to do I
thought oh this will work itself out and
then they just became all [ __ ] glued
up so anyways if you haven't gone
through anything just remotely physical
like that to finally just be able to
[ __ ] and take your shirt off
brush your teeth you know what I mean
I'll put the shaving cream on my head
when I go to shave my head I always had
to put it in the left hand you know
I'm [ __ ] mess
alright here we go Formula One everybody
hey there Billy the red-faced [ __ ] I've
been a longtime listener for about ten
years now and the podcast has always
been a great break from the drudgery of
everyday life especially back at my
university the university days okay I'm
done blowing you know anyways my
grandfather father and I are all car
lovers that's great I remember falling
Formula One closely as a kid when
Jacques Villeneuve and Michael
Schumacher back in 1997 I'm so pissed I
missed that because everybody tells me I
missed a great day as a Formula One
listening to you get into Formula One
had me thinking of getting back into it
myself with that in mind I decided to
buy myself an early birthday president
and bought tickets for the Spanish Grand
Prix in Barcelona for this upcoming
season for my old man and I do that's
the [ __ ] I'm trying to go to two races a
year so I'm trying to figure out what
I'm gonna do
it's either going to be Mexico City in
Brazil or if I do some tour dates over
in Europe I'll just bookend them with
the race we shall see obviously Mexico
City is deceivingly far away from LA
like I always picture that it's just
south of Los Angeles because you know
you just go south and you're in [ __ ]
Tijuana let me look that up where the
[ __ ] is if I you don't want I gotta hold
the microphone here can I can I do this
do I have this ability here we go
North America
I see a map here we go come on come on
slow internet all right
clicking on it oh yeah it's like South
are like [ __ ] Houston or New Mexico
or something like that right all right
where do we go there's Australia with a
[ __ ] am i all right
zooming in I really should have hit
pause
oh yeah Mexico City
like south of San Antonio so it's like
flying all the way to San Antonio it's
like basically flying all the way across
in an all the way south again for almost
the same distance it's probably yeah the
equivalent of flying to like Tampa or
something like that but then Brazil if I
go to Brazil I mean that's all the way I
used to think that went in New York with
my buddies is to go to Brazil that they
were flying due south and that due south
actually would get you into like Peru
other the western side of South America
I would love to go down there too
yeah maybe I'll do that and then I would
actually be done with all the races on
this side of the world who knows that's
such a cool thing that you're doing
doing that with your dad though anyways
plowing ahead I know you like the Air
India team I also like the Williams
martini team I just like the colors and
I don't want to pick a perennial
powerhouse like Mercedes or Ferrari so
my question is which team racer did you
enjoy watching most my father and I are
going to pick a team to route forward
during the upcoming season to make our
father-son weekend a little more fun
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself who did I
like I actually Daniel Ricciardo is
probably you know the closest to Lewis
Hamilton and I would also say I really
liked Jesus I'm so new to the sport and
I haven't thought of them that that guy
oh I know and his teammate there his
teammate was a [ __ ] maniac hold on a
second I gotta make sure nobody switched
on a team let's say Red Bull Racing team
that kid was like twenty years old
drivers here we go kid unless he
switched teams max Verstappen was really
fun to watch I would say out of the
youngers other young drivers he's
probably the best I don't know if he's
still on the team these guys seem to
jump around like free agents and then
it's all about getting on the Ferrari
Mercedes team which you know two seasons
and is getting a little boring so I
would like to see somebody else when you
know so I have Max for stepping I guess
that's what I would I would say that and
I'm that's such a great thing to do I'd
never been to Spain that's amazing I am
gonna be doing a gig I believe to
celebrate my 50th birthday
I believe it's coming together over in
Europe I'm going to go I think I might
be doing a gig somewhere in England and
then I'll be with my lovely wife and
beautiful daughter and maybe we're gonna
go to France again I'll try to polish up
and some of my French but if there's any
races over there
you know what you've inspired me I want
to talk to my the guy who books me today
and I'll be like we got it we got to
figure out you know what Formula One
race is going on over there because I
gotta add that 50th birthday and go to a
Formula One race over in Europe man that
would be sick all right more Formula one
[ __ ] Formula one grid girls
hey billion Wallace and big fan from
Glasgow Scotland Formula One just
announced that they're getting rid of
the grid girls because they feel this
custom does not resonate with our brand
values and clearly is it odd with the
modern-day social societal norms same
thing has happened with the darts and is
looking likely for boxing and UFC in the
future are these probably uh are these
probably ugly feminists doing
nice-looking girls out of a job or are
they doing the right thing alright I
don't know what the [ __ ] I kind of know
what you're trying to say what are your
thoughts cheers and go [ __ ] yourself you
[ __ ]
yeah that's just all you know lip
service no pun intended it's just
[ __ ] you know what I mean
and you know I think it's all [ __ ]
here's the deal to say this custom does
not resonate to say it's clearly is it
odd with modern-day social norms it is
it's a it's 100% at odds with with the
public horseshit
political correctness which all
political correctness really is is being
phony you know what I mean
it's just just denying what you're
really feeling denying what you really
want to say denying what you're really
[ __ ] thinking that's why comedians
seems so [ __ ] outrageous they would
say you're saying the things that people
think but afraid to say if they're not
afraid to say it they say it in their
cars they say with their friends they
say it at home you know I'm not I'm not
talking about being a racist [ __ ]
[ __ ] all right they're basically trying
to say that men do not enjoy looking at
beautiful women this is against a
societal norm that people do not
gravitate towards beauty both male and
female like if you're a good-looking guy
you're not gonna have you pick of the
litter when it comes to women and vice
versa
like if you're a beautiful woman that
you're not gonna have to [ __ ] you
know what I mean I mean you could look
at it in like a negative way I always
thought that because it was outside of
this country that I always thought that
they had a better way of presenting
beautiful women that it wasn't just like
that Hooters vibe that we have here like
look and stick my dick between those
knockers you know the ugly way that we
[ __ ] do everything over here you know
I just I think what that is is they
probably got enough crap from these
women's groups and they just don't need
the headache so and I also feel that a
lot of you know when they say the you
know you're exploiting women and blah
blah blah blah blah I think there's a
lot of truth in that I don't think it's
it's that way with this I think that's
that's you know what are they doing what
exactly they doing are they [ __ ] you
know twerking and all that [ __ ] it's
just a beautiful woman walking around
with the ring card that's it you know
getting attention in a very safe [ __ ]
I mean what is the [ __ ] problem you
know and I do know that you know the way
guys can't handle a good-looking guy
who's [ __ ] Jack down at the end of
the bar you know a better-looking guy
who [ __ ] it good butyou gonna go fight
them you know women do the same thing
with the better-looking woman that comes
walking into the bar they [ __ ] hate
them that's that's it so I think it's
pretty [ __ ] childish
however Formula One is on ESPN and you
know ESPN used to be great but now they
kind of ruin everything so I'm gonna
blame them they are they obviously were
too [ __ ] stupid to keep will Buxton
who was was phenomenal at his job
I don't know so yeah I think that's all
but the whole thing is it's [ __ ] dumb
and eventually there's gonna be a
backlash god forbid there's a beautiful
woman walking around on stage God for
[ __ ] bid and guys are like excited by
it like you know and [ __ ] whistling a
little bit who gives a [ __ ] - who
cares
you know what I mean this is my problem
with feminism is that all the
corrections are made for them which is
really kind of putting it out there as
if that women don't need to adjust their
[ __ ] behavior in any ways when it
comes to men you know and in feminists
get to speak in these unbelievable like
broad no pun intended
blanket [ __ ] statements but guys
cannot you know what I mean I'll speak
in some blanket [ __ ] terms for men
hey how about you earn your own [ __ ]
money how about you buy a round every
once in a while how about when you go
through a [ __ ] divorce you try to do
something fair and try instead of trying
to take every [ __ ] last dime you
possibly can you're greedy [ __ ] alright
we're moving on to the next one
no they don't need to adjust that at all
they don't need to adjust any of their
[ __ ] behavior whatsoever they don't
do anything wrong whatsoever I tell you
right now if women died that much sooner
than men you don't think that there
would be a study you don't think that
there would be a [ __ ]
Ben you don't think some way that they
would blame men on some level that women
die that much earlier than men if it was
that [ __ ] way I don't know I think
that that's why guys are so funny is
because nobody gives a [ __ ] about us
they really don't you know what I mean
they just don't anything that happens to
a guys are duly about songs Allah sucks
to be him right that's it that's the
level of support we have for one another
all right deported father dear Billy
Justice two-and-a-half years ago my
father was deported to Mexico he had
been in the US since 1978 since he was
13 my family struggled without him
financially and emotionally it's been
very rough I must've been brutal he's
healthy and not dead but he can't be
with us yeah that's got to go man it's
[ __ ] brutal it's been very
frustrating and words can't describe it
I'm getting married in a few weeks and
he wasn't able to be at the wedding
every day I see people criticize Trump
and can agree with their reasons for
doing so but my father was deported
under Obama my family knows three other
people who were also deported under
Obama my white friends think they're
good people because they liked Obama but
never looked to see what was happening
they didn't care then but they care now
it makes me feel very mad because it
feels insincere and lazy as a white man
who seems fairly progressive can you
tell me why this is what would you
suggest I say to them it's an emotional
thing for me so it's hard to choose the
right words Congrats on your child I
have two nieces and it's really the
greatest thing to watch them grow thank
you
what can you say to them how it depends
on how open-minded they are people who
are really into politics which means
they 100% watch CNN or Fox News all
[ __ ] day as if they're getting some
sort of fair and unbiased news feed you
really can't say anything to either one
of them I mean there are a lot like
sports fans where I try to see you know
I try to the best I can
to see bowls like I could legitimately
be happy for eagles fence you know I
mean I can legitimately look at [ __ ]
Derek Jeter and say that guy's [ __ ]
great and I can set aside my hatred of
the Yankees are my wanting for my team
to beat the Eagles yesterday but you
know it took me a long time to get there
so I don't know I mean knowing the way I
was wired I would just walk right up to
him beat you you know just so you know
your [ __ ] angel there Obama you know
who for some reason gets no [ __ ]
whatsoever I mean it probably doesn't
hurt that he went that his presidency
was between two of the [ __ ] two of
the biggest [ __ ] dip shits I've ever
seen his [ __ ] dice a dip Shimon said
that cause trying to think over the
[ __ ] word I could say and not be too
[ __ ] offensive and think that I'm a
[ __ ] lefty here 100% which you know
most of the times I am but I mean hey
[ __ ] him hey hey he not get full weekend
went after that and then this guy who
[ __ ] tweets all the time and then
before that you had a guy shoving cigars
and it's been [ __ ] people's [ __ ] I
mean it's been really rough since the
first George Bush who actually had big
you know when we pushed Saddam out of
Kuwait didn't go into [ __ ] Iraq and
was strong enough to push back against
the [ __ ] corporation say hey look
this is not what we were doing over here
we accomplished our mission and what
going home that's it you know so it's
been a long [ __ ] time so I think that
there's a there's a thing with Obama at
least he wasn't Bush or Trump kind of
thing so that people have a hard time
seeing him and I think he gets handled
with kids gloves in the media you know
what I mean they you know every image of
him he's like kayaking or [ __ ]
playing highligh and all of this [ __ ]
like the joke I was doing in my acted
like it looks like an erectile
dysfunction ad and they're really kind
of big
that that guy for all the hope that he
said and everything and I know that that
job is you know well I don't know like
literally no but I I understand that
it's an incredibly difficult job and
they always say if you can get one thing
done which he did he did get Obamacare
through so I guess it was an achievement
but I have to tell you it's someone who
does lean left to watch him go on tour
now with 70 million dollars a tour dates
to go talk to a bunch of [ __ ] bankers
and corporations you know and all of
that and and just I don't know it just
it's as far as the way I read that
that's just those corporations washing
their bribe money like we got you in
office you did what we wanted you to do
now come talk to us for an hour and
we'll give you a nice six-figure
paycheck and we'll all do it and then
you can be worth over a hundred million
dollars like the Clintons like the
bushes and all like it's so [ __ ] up
that none of them get called out on that
it's like the Bush's the Clintons the
Obamas it's like you guys dedicated your
life to public service and the
presidency is the highest paying job
which now is like a half a million
dollars a year if you do two terms
you're gonna gross tops you go what is
that 500 times [ __ ] eight what is
that that's four million bucks and
somehow they all they're buying giant
houses and they all end up being worth
nine figures and everybody just looks
the other [ __ ] way I don't know so
maybe it maybe there's someone within
your group that is understanding enough
and can see both sides of that you know
like if I said what I just said about
Obama to a Trump person they would be a
good maybe going [ __ ] bananas but
then if I even remotely suggested that
Trump seemed a little emotionally
unstable and that it's he's really doing
the country a disservice to be tweeting
in arguing with people on social media
like a seventh grade
I don't even [ __ ] and respond to people
on Twitter when it comes occassionally I
do but this is supposed to be the leader
of the free world trying to get a trump
supporter to admit to how pathetic and
embarrassing that is I mean that's just
kind of the world that we're in right
now but maybe one of those obama
supporters maybe you could you know i
don't know but then also we live in such
a [ __ ] up world I'm gonna believe that
you're actually Mexican you wrote this
and that you're not some white person
that wrote this [ __ ] because they hate
Obama I have no [ __ ] idea
you never know there's no way for me to
vet so if what you just said was true
that is horrific and I understand what
you're saying
about Obama because you know I think the
best thing he had was he could deliver a
speech better than Bush or Trump but at
the end of the day I even though the you
know the needle kind of leaned more left
when he was in office that the ship
stayed on course if you know what I'm
saying
now what I'm running right now I want
that guy from Reno to come walking into
my [ __ ] room here all right
boyfriend's best friend dear Billy Boy
lady here uh-oh here comes some red shoe
diary [ __ ] I've been seeing slash dating
my best friend for almost a year now and
we love listening to your podcast
together it's almost it's absolutely
it's going absolutely [ __ ] wonderful
except for one thing oh well this went
in a completely different direction I
thought you would say you wanted to bang
your [ __ ] boyfriend's best friend all
right okay it's going absolutely [ __ ]
wonderful except for one thing his best
friend sent some pictures of naked slash
slash half naked girls from Instagram to
him
we recently became long distance so I'm
not sure of the frequency still but
before I moved away he did it almost
daily my issue is one his best friend
girlfriends complained to me about it
instead of taking it up with him
and I tell him I tell her to just talk
to him wait wait wait I don't
there's too many [ __ ] pronouns in
here I don't know who the [ __ ] you're
talking about
Oh his best friend's girlfriend so the
the girlfriend of the guy sending the
pictures complains to me about it
instead of taking it up with him and I
tell her to just talk to him and number
two it's actually hard to take that
advice because I don't want him to think
I'm trying to control his life some of
these pictures are actually girls that
they know and not just pictures from the
Chive or the code of man I don't even
what that is my question is do I have
the right to be heard about about about
this well are you heard about this yes
I'm gonna say yes are you a free person
yes as much as they'll let you be so I
would say yes you do if so how do I
bring this up to him I've lost over 30
pounds over the course of us seeing one
another and frankly thought it it would
stop but it hasn't that's not why I lost
the weight by the way did it for myself
okay well that was weird the I thought
Dolph sunny was stressing out on it
thanks for the advice and kindly go [ __ ]
yourself well that's great first of all
you got yourself in great shape you know
is giving you a standing ovation right
now your [ __ ] vitals all your major
organs are loving you as we live in a
world now where everybody's a hero
including overweight people you know
what I mean I'm telling you right now if
your vitals were standing in an airport
you got off a plane that they would not
be giving you a [ __ ] round of
applause staying in shape is the
greatest [ __ ] thing you could ever do
for yourself and you [ __ ] deserve it
all right and [ __ ] stop playing the
victim and do something about it and
mitt to the fact that you're the one
with the hands shoving that [ __ ]
cupcake down your [ __ ] throat sorry
I'm getting off track here
I would actually bring it up with him
that's completely [ __ ] up if that
bothers you you should say something
and that that other guys sending the
photos is being completely disrespectful
to you
and you and your boyfriend you know he's
happy in a relationship why the [ __ ] is
he doing this [ __ ] maybe he's jealous
maybe he's a [ __ ] I have no idea I
would absolutely bring it up to him
and just say it the way you said it like
you know this is some this bothered me
for a long time I you know this is so
weird I actually think if you don't get
emotional if you don't like cry and do
the woman thing which literally freaks
most guys out or maybe I'm superimposing
most guys with the way I feel like when
a woman starts crying I just starting
like Jesus Christ here we go is it now
how do i how do i argue my side now when
you as an adult are actually crying
about this right now
then I'm a pushover okay because anytime
my daughter cries that's it I'm done and
my wife just rolls rolls her eyes at me
just like she's not even crying she's
whining bill I'm like what am I supposed
to do
I just matter-of-factly just say oh no
that really hurts me and but I didn't
want to bring it up to you because I
didn't want to seem like a nag but it's
just lettin you know that that really
bothers me and I don't think it's right
and just imagine if we turn the tables
and one of my girlfriends was sending me
pictures of guys with their dicks out
every day like how would that make you
feel okay I'm not saying you have to
stop doing it I'm just telling you that
it bothers me just put it on that and
let him make the [ __ ] decision rather
than comment because I can tell you as a
typical [ __ ] guy if you come out all
the guys thinking is like oh my god oh
my god how the [ __ ] I mean I understand
that women are more emotional but when
you [ __ ] do that in a lot of ways
it's not fair to the guy because there's
no way you can argue with another adult
that is literally breaking down crying
okay I've been in relationships and I've
seen women crying you know talking to me
about something to this level crying and
I'm thinking
my head like I haven't seen people
crying like this at a Funeral
so it really takes away your ability to
argue your side if you have a side and
that causes resentment you know not to
mention the fact that women can cry on
cue I swear to God I feel like some of
the time it's a minute manipulation
tactics but if you're able to just just
say it and just say I don't want to be a
nag and I'm not saying that he has to
stop doing it I'm just letting you know
that it really bothers me and if it was
going the other way and I was getting
dick pics sent to me every day I don't
think that you'd be too thrilled and
then just let him deal with that and
then be like I'm not gonna say anything
else about it I'm just letting you know
all right and then let him [ __ ] deal
with it and see what he does that would
be my advice all right girlfriend has
higher sex drive than me all right dear
Billy [ __ ] nuts that reminds me of that
classic louis c.k joke to me over that
time when he was dating the nymphomaniac
and she and she kept going let's do it
again
let's do it again and it goes and she
was really just backing into me and it
really [ __ ] hurt and I wanted to say
hey can you stop banging back into me
before you rip my dick off you [ __ ]
psycho but instead I said hey take it
easy all right girlfriend has higher sex
drive than me all right there Billy [ __ ]
nuts I started dating an old girlfriend
from high school after ten years of
being apart Oh like a little When Harry
Met Sally
right I'm now 26 and she's 27 we've been
going steady for about seven months I
love you said we're going steady this
guy's like an old soul and everything
has been great up until around Christmas
where the problem began to give you some
background I work from 7:00 in the
morning she doesn't go to work until
5:00 in the afternoon and gets out at
1:00 oh you go to work at 7:00 the
morning you didn't tell me when you
stopped them she doesn't drive so I have
to pick her up every night the only day
we have off together is every other
Saturday
by the time we get back to my place I'm
completely exhausted and pretty much
falling asleep while she's wide awake
and usually wants to have sex recently
my sex drive has plummeted yeah but
you're not getting any sleep it's gonna
and I can tell you that having a kid now
and that's totally true there's sex in
your relationship
it just takes such a backseat your kid
goes to sleep and it's like hey we could
hook up or we could get like 50 minutes
to sleep and sleep at that point it's
like gold anyways
recently my sex drive is plummeted not
because I don't find her attractive or
because I don't care about her but I'm
just drained of energy after working 50
hours a week with maybe 4 hours of sleep
every night and after about 5 months of
sex every other night it starts to feel
like a chore sometimes I've been turning
her down lately this has caused a lot of
arguments and fights in the past two
months that's probably because she
doesn't know why you know guys you know
generally speaking our horndogs
and any you know you could be in the
middle of [ __ ] having chemo and in
your girl be hey you is [ __ ] do it
you know banging her while you stand up
with that [ __ ] dripping your arm I
feel like she doesn't respect my desire
to get some rest and I've suggested sex
in the morning but at that point she's
already pissed at me all right well if
you communicated it and she's still not
willing to work with you then she's kind
of being immature yeah she seems to
think I don't care about her and that
when I try suggests maybe sex a certain
amount a week like three or four she
gets mad at me and that she always wants
has to initiate it I've been trying to
be more consistent with being sexually
available and more affectionate lately
like visiting her on lunch break and
getting her small glyphs like flowers to
show that I care but the problem is
still here yeah because this is all your
not communicating now when we do
actually have sex sometimes it's just
boring for me because I'm not in the
mood or I really don't have the energy
to do anything but lay there I
love this girl and don't want to lose or
do to something like this you have any
advice for my problem and well when we
come back you bald ginger ball bag I
would say this you guys need to sit down
and have a talk and just say just say
everything you just said to me this is
the problem with most relationships is
people in it say the things that they
should be saying to each other to other
people and then they expect the other
person to be a mind reader she has no
idea that you know how tired you are
just tell her and just tell her that you
love her and ain't you afraid that
you've that you're gonna lose her and
all of that type of stuff and just say
the reason why I'm doing it
not been in the mood is not because you
it's because I'm [ __ ] exhausted I'm
like a zombie I'm getting four hours of
sleep and and just tell her that it
hurts you that you're hurting her so I
really needed to clear the air and just
sit down and clear the [ __ ] air
alright that's what the [ __ ] I would do
okay that's the podcast once again
congratulations to your Super Bowl
champion Philadelphia Eagles like I said
you know I hope you guys know all these
you know I had one bad [ __ ] show in
Philly and everybody thinks I hate the
[ __ ] City I actually love the city
other than the fact you have 58:1 ways
going to the left before there's one
going to the right and then another 58
going left and then 60 going right after
that it makes no [ __ ] sense other
than that yeah I really don't have a
beef with you and a lot of times you
know I wish that show happened in North
Carolina because I would have just stood
on stage making fun of them for losing
the Civil War and the [ __ ] Charlotte
Bobcats and a Hornets and I just make
fun of all that losing their [ __ ]
team and all of that that's what I would
have done I just happened to be I was
actually in New Jersey that's the funny
thing about all of it all right that's
the podcast go [ __ ] yourselves
I will check in on you on what is it
Thursday
alright see